mes chers amis je suis extrêmement
heureuse de vous accueillir tous ici en
ile-de-france une belle région que nous
avons conquise de haute lutte après 17
ans de socialisme il y à un lent alors
alors encore un gros merci à tous ceux
d'entre vous qui ont tout donné tout
donner pour cette belle victoire qui
nous rend aussi fier et comme promis
eh bien depuis un an nous mettons en
oeuvre un programme de franche rupture
pour faire de cette région une région
conquérante exemplaires et réconcilie
alors je sais pas si vous vous souvenez
du du refrain de la coupe du monde
victorieuse 98 et un et deux et trois
zéro
on a eu 1 les municipales et de les
départementales et 3 les régionales et
bien maintenant arrive la mer des
élections l'élection présidentielle
la dernière étape avant l'alternance
mais aussi la plus dure à franchir notre
responsabilité je pèse mes mots et
historique
nous devons redresser la france et
rendre à nos compatriotes l'espérance
alors tout a bien commencé
nous sortons d'une primaire exemplaire
et nous avons toutes les raisons d'en
être fier et à mon tour je crois que
nous devons saluer ensemble l'élégance
le fair play et le panache de tous les
candidats et particulièrement celle de
nicolas sarkozy et alain juppé qui ont
immédiatement appelé à te soutenir
transports
il y a eu le temps des préférences des
différences des nuances mais je le dis
il est derrière nous voici venu le temps
du rassemblement pour gagner les règles
du jeu on les connaît pendant les
primaires ont choisi après la primaire
ont su ni les électeurs de la droite et
du centre ont désigné clairement un
candidat mais ils ont aussi choisi une
ligne politique
ils ont choisi la force de l'expérience
mais ils ont aussi choisi la puissance
de la réforme radicale nous devons
respecter leur choix et faire bloc pour
le redressement national
nous devons nous rassembler sans état
d'âme et je dirais même tout feu tout
flamme
voici venue l'heure du combat collectif
parce que nous voulons transformer
l'essai parce que nous voulons gagner et
parce que nous devons sauver la france
et que c'est maintenant ou jamais alors
françois tu as dirigé pendant cinq ans
le gouvernement mais tu avais mené
auparavant autant ministre de nombreuses
réformes les télécoms l'école les
retraites les français connaissent ils
t'ont vu la leur et ceux qui veulent que
caricaturer en seront pour leurs frais
tu es droits et de droite tuez gaulliste
et humaniste qui chérit notre histoire
et nos terroirs mais tu aime aussi se
projeter dans la modernité
voilà ce dont la france a besoin quand
il est venu me soutenir pour les
régionales à nogent qui a commencé par
un retentissant fons valent elles
et bien moi aujourd'hui je viens te dire
fons françois on est derrière toi
parce que tu as la stature et
l'expérience nécessaires pour relever
une fonction présidentielle
abîmée parce que tu as le courage et
l'audace des vrais réformateurs qui
tiennent beau même dans la tourmente et
permettez moi de vous dire que je parle
d'expérience parce que je les constater
personnellement lors de la réforme des
universités
parce que tu as l'autorité qui impose à
tous le respect et parce que la
république a trop reculé
le populisme d'une marine le pen ou d'un
melanson se nourrissent aujourd'hui et
cette impuissance public
et malheureusement le canadien qui vient
de s'écouler a considérablement aggravé
la situation
madame taubira a amplifié le sentiment
d'impunité des délinquants madame
vallaud belkacem a nivelé par le bas le
collège les audaces de monsieur macron
le mauvais génie du matraquage fiscal
qui nous a fait tant payé d'impôts les
audaces de monsieur macron se sont
résumés à la libéralisation des autocars
et à l'ouverture de certains commerces
certains dimanches matheron c'est
finalement l'ultime avatar de françois
hollande
celui qui commande si bien la situation
et qui agit si peu alors cette
impuissance public elle se ressent aussi
sur le front de la sécurité quotidienne
de la lutte contre l'islamisme radical
mais aussi de l'arrivée sur notre
territoire d'un flux incontrôlé de
migrants et la république exemplaire a
sombré alors oui le quinquennat de
françois hollande a animé la france est
pourtant face à la brutalité de leur
bilan qui a plongé les millions de
français dans la colère la désillusion
est la difficulté
les candidats de la primaire socialiste
semble réfugiée dans le déni
ils ne sont responsables de rien potable
de rails un coupable de rien est ce que
vous les avez regardés jeudi dernier
c'était un peu ennuyeux je le reconnais
c'était surtout surréaliste je sais pas
si vous allez les reconnaître il y avait
là le seul ministre de l'éducation
nationale qui n'a jamais fait de rentrée
scolaire
celui qui s'est fait virer avant benoît
hamon non même si vous jouez poser des
questions réveillez vous un peu là haut
y avait aussi le ministre qui croyaient
que portait une marinière suffirait à
redresser notre industrie bon ça y est
il y avait aussi l'auteur de laquelle a
mis 2 et coûteuse réforme des rythmes
scolaires le ministre de l'éducation
nationale qui a perdu macramé aux
enfants et de leur apprendre à lire
écrire et compter vincent peillon bien
et puis il y avait aussi le sportif il
ya certains sportifs qui s'entraînent à
courir le 50 mètres lui c'est le seul
français qui pratiquent le 49 3 6 fois
en 32 mois un record
mais résumer l'originalité de ses
propositions à la suppression de
l'article 49-3 la constitution de l'âme
il le fait aujourd'hui
permettez moi de vous dire c'est un peu
court au regard des problèmes de la
france c'était manuel valls l'avait
reconnu alors c'est vrai que jeudi soir
sur tf1
on se serait cru devant le maillon
faible sauf que les candidats étaient
tous des maillots faible alors il ya
urgence à toulouse les sorties
de l'autre côté de la galaxie politique
se joue la saga de la pme familiale des
le pen un mixte entre dallas et lee
borgia l'attend désavoue la nièce la
nièce attaque l'attend
quant au père et au grand père d'abord
ils veulent le mettre en maison de
retraite avant de venir lui piquer son
argent il se déchire il le sacco sur
rien une bonne primaires ça leur fait du
bien ça leur permettrait en tout cas
d'élaborer un programme un programme
crédible qui n'en mène pas la france
dans le lire mais au front national les
idées sont à géométrie variable pour ne
pas dire à géométrie électorale
ainsi après avoir mis toute leur énergie
à essayer de conquérir les régions et
devenir président de région avec sa
nièce
voilà que madame le pen souhaite
supprimer les régions ciab renault alors
avant sinon qu'elle voulait supprimer
mais depuis qu'elle a sénat le sénateur
gérard elle pense que le sénat
finalement c'est très utile voilà alors
on a envie de lui dire vous perdez les
présidences de région vous supprimez les
régions et quand vous aurez perdu la
présidentielle vous supprimerez l'état
non quand même pas alors quel contraste
avec toi françois qui nous propose de
faire des réformes profondes et
audacieuse dans un esprit de justice
je tiens à le dire ici avec de telles
réformes
nos voisins ont vaincu la fatalité du
chômage de masse grasse l on peut
relocaliser des emplois industriels
innover et créer les futurs champions
économiques de demain
grâce à elle on peut revaloriser le
travail augmenter les salaires nets
et permettent aux français de vivre
mieux grâce à elle on peut épanouir des
familles dans lesquelles les femmes
n'auront pas à choisir entre travailler
et faire des enfants
grâce à elle on peut donner un avenir à
notre jeunesse ici en france
alors avec le redressement de notre
économie
tu défendra aussi une république
intransigeante
une des filles république du respect oui
dans notre république la loi sera
respectée
nous devons avoir le courage de le dire
si c'est l'honneur de la france
d'accueillir les réfugiés persécutés
dans leur pays
en revanche il est de notre droit
souverain de limiter l'émigration
économique car ces migrants nous n'avons
plus les moyens de leur donner du
travail de les loger de les intégrer les
illégaux les clandestins doivent rentrer
chez eux
c'est notre impuissance se faire
respecter la loi et à maîtriser les flux
migratoires qui nourrit tous les
extrêmes ces têtes au message de nice
dans notre république les forces de
l'ordre les forces de secours seront
respectés françois tu l'as dit à
viry-châtillon la loi des bandes ne peut
pas prévaloir sur la loi commune
il ne peut pas y avoir de zone de non
droit dans notre république
dans notre république les professeurs
seront respectés les actes d'incivilité
les violences se multiplient aujourd'hui
dans nos écoles on le sait et il nous
faut des enseignants de qualité pour que
l'ascenseur social et l'intégration
fonctionne dans notre république et j'y
tiens
les femmes seront respectés il y à un
symbole dévastateur de notre impuissance
à protéger la dignité des femmes c'est
le port impuni de la burqa sur notre sol
vous le savez c'est un combat que je
mène avec ton
c'est je le dis dans notre république la
femme se promène à visage découvert
dans notre république tous les cultes
devront respecter la même charte de la
laïcité ce que l'on a demandé par le
passé aux chrétiens et aux juifs de
france
nous devons aujourd'hui le demandé à
tous les musulmans de france
prêcher en français former les imams
avec le financement étranger des
mosquées contrôler les écoles hors
contrat leur demandait aussi de
condamner fermement le terrorisme
nous devons avoir le courage de faire ce
qui n'a pas été fait depuis des années
pour lutter contre la barbarie islamiste
qui tente d'endoctriner une partie de
notre jeunesse et de l'y faire haïr la
france
il y a urgence cette république
intransigeante cette république du
respect françois qui saura l'incarner
parce que tu serais toi même un
président sobre et respectable un
président à l'autorité naturelle un
président décentralisateur qui libère
les énergies la société qui délègue et
qui fait confiance
faute de cap faute d'intégrité faute
d'autorité faute de justice la france
notre france est abîmée savons pourtant
que nous avons tous les atouts pour la
redresser que nous sommes travailleurs
imaginatif et généreux alors françois
porte notre espoir celui de la fierté
française retrouvée
[Applaudissements]
l'amour de la france le refus du déclin
la volonté d'un sursaut voilà ce qui
nous anime
dans cette campagne françois c'est ton
moment c'est ton destin
nous sommes à tes côtés nous voulons te
donner la force en 1944 dans le journal
combat
albert camus écrivait notre monde n'a
pas besoin d'amis tiède mais le coeur
brûlant et bien aujourd'hui dans cette
salle y a pas d'âme tiède
il n'y a que des coeurs qui brûle avec
toi de changer la france
françois cau la république et pour la
france
[Applaudissements]